Good morning John. It’s Wednesday and uh
something about me has changed and it’s
not my clothes. That’s right I’m wearing
the same clothes I was yesterday, but different
hair.
And John this video is in honor of you because
you put this little meme up on your website
and I’m a big fan of those old Myspace memes
and I kinda wish they wouldn’t have gone
away. Sad that they’re gone. And so I’m
bringing the meme into Brotherhood 2.0 a little
bit here. Let’s call this meme for lack
of a better name: “Google Verb”. It works
like this: You google your name with a verb.
And then you find out what you did. Here we
go!
Google Verb number 1:
Hank needs…
Hank needs… a hug. Aww. (hugs camera). Thanks
everybody for that giant Youtube hug.
Hank looks like…
Hank looks like a pretty princess. Oddly enough
that one was actually about me. It was a title
of a video in reference to my World Wide Web
girl video. With the pigtales. Yeah.
Hank says…
Hank says don’t rush to judgment; which
is good advice.
Hank wants…
Hank wants to play too, but he never gets
to.
Hank does…
Hank does a dance! (dances)
Hank hates…
Hank hates you all! No he doesn’t. He doesn’t.
He doesn’t hate you all.
Hank asks…
Hank asks what to do with the body and Mr.
Bennett says for him to prepare it for shipping.
That’s scary.
Hank likes….
Hank likes to watch men pee on Flickr. I’m
starting to get a little bit upset about this.
Hank eats…
Hank eats a glob of bacon grease and gets
deathly sick. I’m not making these up! I
hope Hank is not a person. I hope Hank is
a dog.
Hank wears...
Hank wears a golden helmet while rafting the
Zambezi river. Hank sounds like he’s having
a very good time!
Hank was arrested for...
Hank was arrested for robbing the National
Bank of Greece but later found innocent.
And finally,
Hank loves..
Hank loves Smosh. Even though Smosh is spelled
wrong, apparently I still love Smosh which
is true.
You guys you crack me up. Anyway Hank’s
life sounds significantly more interesting
than mine what with the rafting and the watching
people pee and so on.
So all that's left now is for you to play
the Google Verb Meme too. All you have to
do is do what I just did. All the questions
are in the sidebar and leave your video as
a reply to this one. I’m going to go ahead
and tag five people because I want them to
do this because I think it would be funny.
I’m tagging Nerimon and I think you all
know why; Dr. Noise, Sistersalad, Short sisters,
and pilocrates.
John I will see you later.